[Musik]
ja liebe zuschauer was für ein
dramatisches spiel 22 gegen ungarn in
deutschland rettet sich so gerade noch
vor dem aus in der em vorrunde durch das
späte tor von leon goretzka wir wollen
wieder darüber reden mit roland zorn dem
langjährigen fußballchef frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung
ja lieber roland erst das offensiv mauer
0 zu 1 gegen frankreich das 4 2 gegen
portugal mit reisen jetzt das zittrige
22 gegen ungarn dms für deutschland
bisher eine achterbahnfahrt wie schätzt
du dass ein wie ist das zu erklären ich
würde sogar sagen das war manchmal eine
geisterbahn trat gestern die dann noch
irgendwie zu einem glücklichen ende
wollte man auf das ergebnis chancen auf
die qualifikation für das achtelfinale
mit platz zwei aber es ist nicht ganz
unproblematisch für diese mannschaft die
ja im grunde erst spät zusammengestellt
wurde wenn man dann denkt er
schlüsselspieler die zurückgeholt wurden
wie mats hummels und auch müller der
jetzt am anfang zuschauern musste wegen
seiner leicht verletzung dass das alles
noch nicht so synchronisiert ist und
sowieso bei der deutschen
nationalmannschaft in den letzten jahren
seit 2008 zehn vieles eher improvisiert
als zusammengewachsen wird dann darf man
sich nicht wundern wenn sich das gleiche
strickmuster auch während eines großen
turniers zeigt das einzig tröstliche ist
bei anderen mannschaften die höher
eingeschätzt sind ist es so ähnlich so
auch bei england im nächsten gegner
der klassiker im achtelfinale den
wembley stadion auf dem wir uns
natürlich freuen können
die haben bisher noch kein richtig gutes
spiel gemacht die deutschen wenigstens
eins aber eine konstante hatten die
deutschen den spielen sie haben immer
das erste tor bekommen und damit einmal
verloren einmal mit viel dusel noch
unentschieden gespielt und einmal daraus
einen glanzvollen sieg gemacht
vielleicht können sie da auch mal so ein
bisschen labil werden und diesmal das
erste tor selbst schießen gegen
ja du hast die abwehr probleme
angesprochen in drei spielen gab es
insgesamt schon fünf gegentore lässt
sich das jetzt in der kürze der zeit bei
einem turnier überhaupt noch lösen
irgendwie also systematisch und durch
ständiges arbeiten lässt sich das
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so ganz lösen
war es auch so unterschiedliche typen
sind man muss bedenken die spielen jetzt
in einer dreier-abwehr haben in den
letzten jahren vorzugsweise mit einer
vierer abwehr gespielt allerdings
meistens auch wieder mit anderem
personal dann haben sie in dieser 3 hp
den rüdiger der so ein bisschen so ein
freischaffender künstler ist der nicht
so praktisch verlässlich ist in manchen
dingen und sich und manchmal weiter
vorne und tod so auch gestern vor dem
ersten ungarischen tor das dann auf
hummels und hinter die idee bänder
standen zusammen bei denen man am ende
auch keiner wusste wer geht hin zu dem
schul und wer nicht es war ein schönes
tor mit dem flugkopfball und dann kommt
der hummels spät rein da muss ich auch
erst wieder in der abwehr einfinden der
bräuchte natürlich auch laufstarke jungs
um sich herum das ist ja der rüdiger das
ist auch der winter und auf der rechten
seite hat sich auch früh verhakte und
verändert und die eigentlichen
außenstürmer nani auf der einen seite
und habe als auf der anderen
sie sollten ja über die halb rollen
bekommen so was zumindest höchst klaren
kann dabei auch nicht vor
gegen eine sehr gut aufgestellte massive
ungarische abwehr so dass es an allen
ecken und enden können durchkommen gab
und auch vor allem keinen plan
der junge eingewechselte ja mal musealer
für jahr auf entscheidenden tor zum 2 2
beteiligt war war er vielleicht dieser
spieler denen den es brauchte wie groß
und es gegen portugal um der sache noch
die richtige wende zu geben
ja der war zwar nur kurz da aber das
kurz und knackig und richtig gemacht er
hat keine nerven gezeigt der hat das
selbstbewusstsein des 18-jährigen
mitgebracht er über ein hohes
technisches potenzial verfügt der beim
fc bayern sehr gut ausgebildet worden
ist und der auch in diesem
in räumen in diesem gewusel eben
ungarischen strafraum genau die lücke
also die lücke gefunden hat die dann am
ende den spieler ermöglichte aus dem
heraus wo es kann auch viel zu spät
eingewechselt den hätte ich von anfang
an in der mannschaft lieber gesehen
mit der entschlossenheit die ihn in
abschluss situation auszeichnet dann das
erlösende tor zum 2 2 gemacht hat die
beiden waren absolut treffer die musiker
ist einer dem man wirklich im auge
behalten sollte für die nächsten spiele
zumal es jetzt ja gegen sein halbes oder
dreiviertel heimatland england geht
vielleicht solltet ihr etwas näher an
die stammelf er in der branche mit ja du
hast das angesprochen haben am dienstag
im achtel vergeht es in wembley gegen
england die deutschen klang ja irgendwie
nach dem spiel gestern durchaus
optimistisch wie siehst du die chancen
auf das weiterkommen ins viertelfinale
da muss man glaube ich von fiftyfifty
sprechen also was haben wir mit unseren
prognosen bisher daneben gelegen also es
wird ganz schwierig aber eine konstante
gehen die engländer auch offenbart
formschwäche in allen drei spielen die
haben jetzt zwei tore geschossen aber
noch keins bekommen bei denen ist die
abwehr eingespielt im übrigen auch eine
firat wer bin ich mich jetzt nicht
täusche und die zu knacken dürfte nicht
so leicht sein und erfordert dann eben
auch ein ausgeklügeltes ein gutes
angriffs konzept also ich glaube alle
spieler inklusive trainer müssen
wirklich die köpfe zusammenstecken vor
diesem spiel
das muss so viel besser werden dass es
tatsächlich nur besser werden
dafür haben wir jetzt ein paar tage zeit
uns noch zu erholen von dem gestrigen
spiel und dann auf england vorzubereiten
wir gucken uns das natürlich wieder an
und sprechen danach auch sogar vielen
dank für deine einschätzung lieber
roland sackers zumindest mal